[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Ihr habt euch wieder ein schnelles Rezept gewünscht.
Deswegen gibt es heute etwas ganz Schnelles.
[Doing] Ich bestelle Pizza und Pasta beim…
Nein, wir machen es natürlich selbst,
denn noch schneller als bestellen und liefern lassen
ist ein One-Pot-Gericht.
Deswegen sind wir, muss ich sagen, mit dem Murat immer,
wenn wir es samstags und sonntags ruhiger angehen lassen wollen,
was essen wir denn jetzt?
Dann sind wir eigentlich immer in der Diskussion:
Kurz bestellen oder liefern lassen
oder doch schnell ein One-Pot-Gericht?
Oftmals gewinne ich mit dem One-Pot-Gericht,
aber ich lasse mich auch gern mal beliefern
und esse natürlich auch gern, ohne dass ich was dafür tun muss.
Aber heute gibt es ein schnelles One-Pot mit Lachs.
One-Pot-Gerichte bedeutet, alles aus einem Topf, wenig Geschirr
und im Prinzip könnt ihr Zutaten verwenden, die ihr alle
gerade dahabt, ein bisschen Resteverwertung aus dem Kühlschrank
- alles, was euch schmeckt, ist erlaubt.
Heute machen wir ein One-Pot-Lachsgericht,
im Prinzip wie Tagliatelle al Salmone, was der Murat ganz gern isst.
Ich bereite es aus tiefgefrorenem Lachs zu. Das habe ich immer da.
Ihr könnt auch frischen verwenden.
Ich gebe noch Räucherlachs mit rein, aber wie gesagt,
wenn ihr eine oder andere Zutat nicht dahabt, tauscht sie einfach aus.
Dafür nehme ich 250 g tiefgefrorenen oder frischen Lachs, 1 Zwiebel,
1 Knoblauchzehe, Cocktailtomaten, 200 g Babyspinat,
250 g Nudeln – ich habe jetzt hier Tagliatelle -, etwas Wasser, Sahne,
Gemüsebrühe, Frischkäse, 1 Biozitrone, Räucherlachs,
Grana Padano – also Parmesan – und Salbei, Salz Pfeffer.
So, das war’s. Eigentlich könnt ihr entscheiden,
ob ihr alle Zutaten roh in den Topf gebt oder ob ihr ein bisschen
Röstaromen bei den Zwiebeln und beim Knoblauch erzeugen wollt.
Das mache ich jetzt.
Also theoretisch, wie gesagt, könnt ihr alles da reingeben,
aber ihr könnt auch Röstaromen erzeugen.
Ich schäle die Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehe und würfle sie.
Eine Zutat habe ich vergessen, und zwar das Olivenöl.
Das ist natürlich wichtig zum Anbraten.
Das habe ich vergessen mit aufzuschreiben und mit hinzustellen,
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm. Es steht nämlich da bereit.
Das Öl kann ich jetzt schon einmal erwärmen.
[Musik]
Ich brate jetzt die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel an.
Einfach bei mittelhoher Hitze mit Deckel etwa 5 Minuten.
Dann kann ich den Lachs schon einmal einfach in Würfel schneiden.
Dann hier die Tomaten halbieren.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr diese Röstaromen nicht wollt,
könnt ihr einfach alles in den Topf geben, ohne vorher anzubraten.
Dann geht es nämlich noch schneller.
Aber ich will ja auch, dass es geschmacklich perfekt wird.
Im Prinzip habe ich diese geschnitten.
Babyspinat – gut, das ist jetzt kein Babyspinat,
aber die anderen Blätter sind eigentlich schon relativ babyklein -
werde ich jetzt nicht zerkleinern, aber wenn ihr
große Spinatblätter habt, dann auf jeden Fall zerkleinern.
Ich gucke sie noch einmal durch, aber das passt.
Dann warte ich jetzt hier kurz, bis die Zwiebeln angebraten sind.
So sehen die Zwiebeln gut aus. Da fülle ich jetzt das Wasser rein
und kann hier den Frischkäse verrühren.
Wenn ich den jetzt so hineingebe, dann kann es sein, dass er klumpt.
Deswegen kurz mit der Sahne anrühren
und auch gern die Gemüsebrühe dazugeben.
Ich habe jetzt hier meine selbstgemachte Gemüsebrühpaste.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch fertige Gemüsebrühe nehmen.
Ich gebe sie euch einfach immer so im Blog als Zutat an,
als wäre es eine fertige Paste bzw. eine fertige Masse.
Aber das Rezept findet ihr auch auf meinem Kanal.
Dann gern noch Zitronenabrieb, wenn ihr es gern mögt.
[Musik]
Etwas Zitronensaft
und Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Drei Stunden später…
Und hier passt auch noch ein bisschen Muskat gut dazu.
Kurz verrühren.
Jetzt könnt ihr im Prinzip alle Zutaten mit in den Topf geben. Ups.
Ich gebe einmal den Spinat unten hinein,
denn es sieht jetzt nach ziemlich viel aus,
aber der fällt gleich zusammen.
Vielleicht packe ich ihn in 2 Portionen hinein,
dass ein Teil schon einmal zusammenfällt
und der nächste Teil kommt dann dazu.
Jetzt kommen auch die Nudeln roh mit rein; alle anderen Zutaten auch.
Ihr könnt auch einen größeren Topf nehmen.
[Musik]
Ihr müsst es jetzt natürlich nicht so schön anordnen,
aber wir haben gerade noch Bilder gemacht.
Deswegen wollte ich einfach den Vorher-Nachher-Effekt.
Jetzt im Prinzip einfach noch die Sahne zugießen
und dann aufkochen lassen.
Wie gesagt, den Spinat gebe ich in 2-3 Portionen dazu,
damit er schön zusammenfallen
und ich den dann immer wieder einrühren kann.
[Musik]
Oh, das sieht so lecker aus.
Ich liebe One-Pot-Gerichte einfach.
Einfach ab und zu, alle 4-5 Min., einmal rühren.
Die Garzeit kommt natürlich ein bisschen auf die Nudelsorte an,
die ihr verwendet.
Wenn ihr seht, dass die Nudeln schon gar sind,
aber noch Flüssigkeit da ist, lasst ihr den Deckel offen.
Wenn noch Flüssigkeit benötigt wird,
gebt ihr noch etwas dazu – ganz einfach!
Ich habe hier jetzt noch Räucherlachs. Das muss nicht sein,
aber der bringt hier natürlich noch einen
leckeren geräucherten Geschmack dazu.
Dann lasse ich das Ganze noch ein kurz durchziehen
und wir können schon direkt probieren.
Bei mir gibt es einfach noch einen frischen Salat dazu und fertig.
Fertig ist das 15-Minuten-Gericht.
[Musik]
SAMIRA: Guck mal, ich habe noch Lachs auf den Löffel getan.
SALLY: Ja, du willst viel Lachs, oder?
SAMIRA: Ja, und viel Nudeln.
SALLY: Gut. Also heute darf Samira probieren.
Was ich noch sagen wollte:
Bei mir ist es mit der Kochzeit so,
ich habe jetzt hier im Gusseisentopf gekocht.
Ich habe wirklich den Herd nur 5 Min. an, lasse das Ganze 5 Min.
köcheln, schalte den Herd dann komplett aus,
denn der Gusseisentopf speichert wirklich die ganze Hitze.
Dann kann das Gericht einfach
ohne Energie etwa 10 Min. lang weitergaren.
Dann zerfällt der Lachs auch nicht so arg
und die Nudeln verkochen nicht
und ich habe im Prinzip einfach nur noch umgerührt. Das war’s.
Probier‘ mal! Ich probiere auch.
Darf ich bei dir probieren? [Samira bejaht]
Samira liebt Lachs.
SAMIRA: Seit neustem.
SALLY: Seitdem ihr das mit Greta auf dem Grill gemacht habt, oder?
[Samira stimmt zu]
Boah, der wird echt perfekt, weil er nicht so zerfällt.
SAMIRA: Boah, richtig lecker!
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Ich glaube, das bedeutet, dass es gut schmeckt.
Wenn es Samira isst, essen es bestimmt auch eure Männer und Kinder.
Doch, schmeckt gut, oder? [Samira stimmt zu]
Also die Zutaten findet ihr in meiner App oder auf Sallys-Blog.de.
Probiert das Rezept gern aus und dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß beim
Nachkochen. Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Ihr könnt ja einmal schreiben, ob ihr generell wieder mehr One-Pot
sehen wollt oder doch wieder ganz herkömmliche, aufwendigere Gerichte.
Bei mir ist es immer so ein Wechsel: Mal habe ich Lust auf so etwas,
aber mal habe ich auch Lust, mich richtig in der Küche auszutoben.
Von daher schreibt mir einfach. Bis bald! Tschüss.
SAMIRA: Gibst du mir noch ein bisschen?
SALLY: Na klar! Komm. Warte kurz. Ich gebe dir gleich einen Teller
und dann kannst du mit deiner Freundin zusammen essen, okay?
[Musik]